while the Ukrainian ambassador to the UK
van impristaiko is with us um hello to
you so thank you for joining us can we
start with that exclusive report there
from Alex back moot depends who you talk
to as to whether it's strategically
important or not what's your view I
believe it is important to engage their
forces to allow us a bit more time to
Resort reinforce we reschedule our
supplies and start our counter-offensive
same amount of losses on both sides were
being told at the moment I can imagine
the losses are huge we don't know the
exact number means the Russians by the
way but you know nobody knew this town
even in Ukraine before it was not that
significant it's not that big but how
many lives were lost I believe they will
come in the history books why did why do
your does your government not tell us
about casualties
because we are 18 times more than Russia
we have to find the strength to fight
back we have to fight our soldiers among
the civilians but that's what we're
doing right now we're training them so
we don't want to the enemy know how much
resource we still have but we have
enough the million people were already
trained and went through the war effort
this huge Army is you need more
ammunition definitely we need more
ammunition not the light arms we need
more ammunition sophisticated as we
discussed with you many times the small
Red Army won't defeat the Big Red Army
so we have to get back better than this
Russian army talk to us about your
president's uh Whistle Stop tour of
Europe why was he doing that
because we are obviously preparing for
the very big push and we need to secure
some of the supplies we need to secure
some of the intelligence and sometimes
this political support what we are now
receiving see with all these
announcements of the NATO support and
all of this the Reconstruction which was
coming here to in the next month this is
all important it's one big package
joined up thinking with all of the
European countries or or is the
president having to do different deals
with each one I believe that Europe is
very much United right now is getting
there it's it's we started quite quite
difficult we have to explain to each and
every nation some Nations where the
front line like like yourselves the
United States Canada but then then you
know look at the Germany then our second
biggest supplier of the arms and they
started with 500 helmets that's true why
does he feel the need to to travel to
these countries so because of course he
up until recently he hasn't traveled at
all out of the country yeah he's quite a
busy man I agree with you but I it's not
a secret that this is very important
this particular counter-offensive and so
many people are putting their bets on
how Ukrainian Army will perform and from
there they will make up their minds
whether to help us to help us with more
stuff or to cool it down what's his
relationship with your president's
relationship with Rishi sunak as opposed
to Boris Johnson
I believe that president zielinski is a
noble person this this himself he likes
people he's he found himself in totally
different sort of you know situation
when he expected when he was going to
the presidency but he likes people he
established these context and although
your prime minister Johnson and the
current prime minister are very
different people Brazilians can find
something very person both of them
you talk about the approach we'd heard
it be described previously as the spring
offensive
um there will be a significant loss of
life on both sides I'm anticipating I
totally aware of that and I knew it from
the very first day half more than one
year and a half ago that it will cost us
daily we're talking this studio I told
you that it won't be working part will
fight and we knew that many wild people
will die both military and civilians but
that's the price we're paying for our
way of overliving and that continues
even in the capital thankly no deaths
with the the latest assault but
nonetheless Russia tried to send you
another message overnight my brother is
sending me real messages the pictures
from from Key of keys and give this his
family so I quite know what is happening
there but even he's saying after this
year of War this is getting really
really scary so I understand the message
and all of us do but we sometimes
managed to get all the hundred percent
of the rockets and drones being sent
against us with the help of our many
many many friends and look at the
Germans supplied the irst the this this
machine this equipment which allows 100
of hits so we are trying to to you know
to secure our skies that's why we need
the the Jets you know to really clear
them out of our skies
I really promised Jets though were you
during his
during his day we've been promised very
important stuff is the pilot training
you know we had this strange
conversation this vicious circle of
conversation one may have to explain our
partners that we need plans and they
will tell yeah but the training of
Pilots will take two years I would say
exactly if we started training before
like a year ago we would have now almost
trained pilots and then we decide
political decision will be taken which
planes will take now we'll make our mind
we need f-16s at least now
who might come to different times about
f-16s I know but you can provide our
basic training and again as many cases
before you are sort of pushing the
boundary a bit pushing the line crossing
the next maybe it's not red line but
very important line for many other
allies so does that mean that given that
Pilots take two years to be trained that
you're expecting this war to go on for
that long no we're not expecting what we
expect and what we know that we have
trained pilot which are flying right now
now via airplanes they're a bit
different but this is trade Pilots some
of them had hundreds and hundreds of
flights it's not just flights the Flies
this battle so they are very much
prepared we need to train them how to
switch to the combined sort of fight
with different flights of the different
Jets on somebody's else Jets
do
um wonder what's happened to Alexander
lukashenko obviously we're wondering and
we understand that in their society they
very much more or less everything
depends on the leader because it is
dictatorial regime so the change of
regime will will definitely bring the
change to the society and we have to be
prepared we are very close to below
Russian that's more or less the same
Nation as us so we want them to live
better we want them to learn from our
lessons and this one of the lessons we
have to get to read from the dictators
do you think that he will return to his
Edition he might return but his position
is weakened not by his health now which
is additional sort of weakness but by
his position with the Putin he is
positioning himself with the Putin
against everybody else what do you
think's happened to him
listen I don't actually want to know
that the personal life and personal
health story I might have sympathy
sympathetic to personal I met him a
couple of times person when I worked
before
what's what bothers me that how it will
bring the whole nation down the whole
system because it is so much
hierarchically centered around him all
these people around him all the cronies
are you not more anxious that somebody
who may replace him would be more of a
Putin even more of a Putin supporter we
heard about that Putin what would happen
if Putin steps down and somebody else
will come let's wait and see I know that
many many Bill Russians are supporting
us there is a thinking that that he is
not in the war with Russian because he
is not sure if he gives the weapons the
live weapons to his people where they
will turn this this kalashnikovs against
maybe him so the people in Belarus we
believe that will be they will be very
supportive they will just need a chance
to clear their own system okay
um we spoke up recently about the
situation in Odessa when it comes to
grain it does look as though that's
stalled again for now what is the latest
situation as you understand it
yeah this this deal this grain deal
which is in our case this allowing us to
you know turn in our money in dignity
that's our grain we wanted to sell it
but it's more important that we're
feeding so many hundreds of millions
around the globe and because Russians
also understand the political importance
of this they are blocking the finding
different different reasons not to allow
it to happen the biggest problem is now
that the first then bombarding the silos
where we're keeping them and we have new
new harvests coming this is the biggest
problem and you know people know that
you can replace ships with the trains I
have those calculations and we'll need
four years of all the trains used just
to be able to take all this great wish
with the ships are taking okay so who
can help
uh we are helping we've been helped by
turkey we've been helped by un but what
will really help if we finish up the
world will clear up the mines in the
Black Sea because it's again mine after
after 70 years of big war so then the
ships will come back and get all the
grain okay when can we see president
zelenski in the UK again
you know sometimes like the surprises we
we have to keep this way until the war
is over okay quite a surprise to us I'm
sure it wasn't to you not that much but
also it's quite surprising okay it's
great to see you thanks for coming in to
talk to